[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle et agriculture alimentation
cuisine mais aussi politique et cette
semaine nous recevons Jean-Marc zoulesi
et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour Jean-Marc lésy
bonjour et merci pour l'invitation
bonjour Jean-Marc zoulesi vous êtes donc
président de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire de
l'Assemblée nationale député des
Bouches-du-Rhône depuis 2017 vous êtes
ingénieur de formation et avant de vous
engager derrière Emmanuel Macron vous
avez travaillé dans une société
spécialisée dans les dispositifs de
protection contre les rayons
ionisants c'est-à-dire les rayonnements
produits par la radioactivité c'est tout
un savoir auteur d'un rapport sur les
mobilités vous avez été rapporté sur le
volet transport de la loi climat et
résilience vous faites aussi partie de
ces quelques députés qui ont lors du
précédent mandat votez l'amendement pour
interdire le glyphosate originaire de
Marseille vous avez choisi dans votre
menu de mettre en valeur votre terroir
n'est ce pas Jean-Pierre effectivement
avec un parfum du Sud et une soupe au
pistou et en dessert une tarte aux
abricots dans le dessous des plats et si
le maïs restait en carafe faute d'eau il
pourrait disparaître la COP 27 qui
s'ouvre en Egypte se penche sur les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
dans les pieds dans le plat un des bacs
qui agitent nos campagnes faut-il
installer des panneaux photovoltaïques
sur des terres arables allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence
alors Jean-Marc je lui ai dit c'est
comme ça lorsqu'on invite un député
marseillais il y a tout de suite un
parfum classique au qui flotte dans
l'air la preuve je m'attendais à vous
voir à table avec la tunique bleu ciel
de l'OM au temps pour vous mettre les
Ultra dans la poche que le président
Macron mais non l'abandon de la cravate
dans l'hémicycle ne vous a pas
complètement désinhibé en revanche et je
livre là quelques secrets de fabrication
de cette émission Brigitte vous aviez
demandé une bouillabaisse peu chère mais
le restaurant parisien chez Françoise
qui nous sert habituellement a senti le
traquenard et à beauté en touche une
bouillabaisse dans les règles de l'art
avec les poissons de Rungis à la place
des rascasses rouges des rougets ou de
la Galinette des Calanques trop
casse-gueule donc banco pour le plan B
l'iconique soupe au pistou moins risqué
moins ancré dans l'ADN de la gastronomie
marseillaise en plus cette soupe évoque
davantage la Provence de pagnols que les
travées du vélo de Rome donc on devrait
Brigitte déjeuner en paix sans refaire
le match en dissertant plutôt sur les
vertus du basilic et sur le les secrets
de cette soupe verte que vous vénérez
j'espère cela venir effectivement la
vénéré
dans la famille dans cette dans cette
soupe au pistouilles d'abord la Provence
et
et vous dire aussi que pour faire cette
soupe aux pistou il faut beaucoup
d'efforts d'abord pour ramasser les
légumes ramasser des haricots j'ai
travaillé auprès d'agriculteurs
notamment sur ma commune de
Cornillon-Confoux parce que je ne suis
pas marseillais je suis avant tout
salaudé mais attention je viens d'un
village qui s'appelle corniaud CONFOUX
j'ai travaillé chez un agriculteur
monsieur Moreau qui m'a qui m'a
d'abord apporter ce goût du travail et
pour mener à bien ce travail et bien ça
demande beaucoup d'efforts ramasser des
haricots venez avec moi ce n'est pas
évident donc c'est le fruit dans la
beurre et puis il y a des moments aussi
de convivialité en famille puisque vous
retrouvez un certain nombre de notamment
des haricots blancs des haricots rouges
qu'il faut égrainer et donc ça c'est des
soirées d'été en famille
vous devez égrener les haricots les
Écossais comme on dit chez nous et c'est
des moments de
durant ces moments d'été et puis
orphelmonde j'imagine quand on est causé
haricots on fait le match on refait le
monde on fait la vie marseillaise on
refait le match malgré la défaite de
l'Olympique de
Marseille mais et puis
derrière ce plat il y a aussi quelque
chose d'assez personnel puisque
c'est un moment derrière ce plat je
retrouve bien le le
capacités de ma maman à faire la soupe
au pistou ah ça y est j'étais sûr qu'il
y avait une maman derrière et ces
moments de famille le dimanche le
dimanche après-midi ou ensemble on se
réunit en famille pour partager la soupe
au pistou et donc je crois que dans la
période se dire aussi que on est en
capacité de s'appuyer sur sa maman sa
famille ses parents et bien c'est
important de pouvoir se retrouver voyez
le dimanche midi autour d'une bonne
soupe au pistou sur l'essentiel
de votre maman même si chez Françoise la
prépare très bien mais vous allez nous
dire si elle est bonne si elle est
réussie pendant ce temps là Jean-Pierre
trois choses à savoir pour pour bien
réussir sa soupe
pistou pas forcément la soupe aux pistou
de Madame zoulesi il faut d'abord bien
laisser mijoter pendant au moins une
heure tous les légumes vous les avez
cités coco rouge et blanc courgette
carottes pommes de terre tomate quand
c'est la saison oignon pomme de terre je
l'ai déjà dit dans un gros bouillon pour
bien mélanger toutes les saveurs 2
pendant que ça mijote et bien vous
sortez le mortier pas le mortier pour
faire la guerre mortier vous savez c'est
un vase un peu abrasif dans lequel on va
mettre les feuilles de basilic quelques
gousses d'ail jusqu'à former une espèce
de pommade puis ensuite on ajoute
l'huile d'olive là aussi c'est du boulot
quand vous parliez de travail là aussi
c'est de l'huile de coude qu'on va
utiliser bien sûr cette huile d'olive en
filet afin d'obtenir une sauce ultra
verte ultra concentrée en basilique très
odorante et puis trois attention cette
sauce surtout ne la faites pas cuire
sinon vous allez flinguer tous les
arômes du basilic vous la rajoutez au
dernier moment dans la soupe chaude hors
du feu et vous servez immédiatement ce
qui a été fait ici la sauce était mise à
part par Françoise et on l'a servi
la sauce dans la casserole histoire
d'exhaler les parfums intenses du pistou
c'est la bonne exactement alors c'est la
bonne recette mais ce qu'il faut faire
c'est tout en plus c'est que chaque
famille a le secret de ce que vous
appelez la pommade c'est potion un peu
magique où chaque famille est bien mais
un peu plus d'ail un peu plus un peu
plus de basilic certains rajoutent aussi
des pignons pour donner un peu de
consistance et donc bon cette soupe au
Pisto est excellente et elle ne vaut pas
celle de ma maman ça manque un peu d'ail
ça manque un peu d'ail autant de
recettes de soupe au bistou que de
famille marseillaise c'est exactement ça
et puis il me semble que c'est Auguste
Brown qui en parlait très bien
cet écrivain provençal qui avait mis
justement un peu en avant les secrets de
cette soupe au pistou bon tout ça pour
vous dire que derrière cette soupe au
pistou il y a la convivialité il y a de
l'effort mais il y a surtout la Provence
qui chante et vous vous savez la
préparer vous en fait maintenant vous
vous avez perdurer cette cette recette
familiale que préparer votre maman je
suis en pleine phase de d'apprentissage
mais ça demande du temps et beaucoup
d'efforts là aussi et pour le basilic
vous êtes au mortier vous êtes plutôt au
mixeur vous non il faut il faut faire ça
au mortier mortier si vous voulez garder
les saveurs il faut faire ça est-ce que
tous les tous les légumes sont
réglementaires là dans cette soupe aux
Picsou parce que moi j'avais compris
qu'il y avait que des légumes d'été donc
pas de carottes alors je n'ai pas osé
vous le dire mais si ma maman ma maman
vous voyez non les carottes non en
partie exactement non il faut vraiment
que ça soit que des que des légumes
parce que j'ai aussi cité les carottes
tout à l'heure alors
d'été exactement et il y a pas il y a
des pâtes où il y a des normalement il y
a des pâtes aussi
revisitée par chez Françoise chez nous
on dirait les Parisiens voilà il faut
des petits vermicelles normalement
on a des coquillettes c'est accepté
exactement et ça se mange aussi bien
chaud que froid ou ça se mange tiède
comme là elle nous est servi
c'est que ça agrémente aussi la vie des
villages puisque l'été en tant qu'elu je
suis invité à des fêtes de village et
vous avez soit traditionnel aïoli soit
la soupe et là aussi tout le village se
retourne se retrouve derrière cette
aïoli cette soupe au pistou et c'est ce
qui permet aussi d'avoir des moments
politiques puisque tous les élus sont
invités et une rencontre avec les
citoyens mais c'est aussi un moment de
convivialité qui est super bonne ancien
bon enfant mais est-ce que cette saison
cette soupe est-ce qu'on la mange
l'hiver alors non
il faut être un peu en cohérence pas
l'hiver ou alors certains congèle la
soupe au pistou pour la ressortir
l'hiver mais vous perdez de la saveur
c'est un plat donc soyons du joint on
leur demande une soupe d'été l'hiver
donc ils nous mettent quelques
de l'histoire et je n'oublie pas que
c'est moi qui en ai fait la demande donc
il y a pas de pas de difficulté avec ça
mais vous avez raison normalement c'est
un produit avant tout c'est un plat
d'été avec des produits d'été mais vous
êtes pardonné parce que c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment c'est plus bien s'il était est
terminé surtout à Marseille et on trouve
encore des légumes d'été effectivement
il y a d'autres recettes de chez vous
que vous voulez nous faire partager que
vous aimez manger en famille ou que vous
cuisinez peut-être alors la soupe au
pistes tout l'aïoli la bouillabaisse
mais aussi les panisses je sais pas si
vous avez déjà entendu parler Le Panisse
ah si alors moi je suis un fan je
voulais cuisiner vous les savez les
faire oui je sais les faire c'est pas
très compliqué il faut juste aller à
l'ESTA que vous prenez justement la
crème de pois chiche en fait de la
farine de la farine de poisson mélange
avec de l'eau un peu d'huile d'olive
c'est exactement ça et la bonne huile
d'olive ça j'insiste bien parce que que
ça soit pour les panisses ou pour cette
soupe au pistou il faut une huile
d'olive de qualité et pourquoi est-ce
que je vous en parle parce que
actuellement les moulins de Provence
sont en pleine activité puisque nous
recevons les la récoltes des olives et
donc j'étais la semaine dernière
notamment au moulin des Costes à
Pélissanne qui reçoit
les olives et on a là aussi différentes
types d'huile d'olive le sujet de la
fruité vert de la fruité maturée et donc
derrière il y a toute une culture liée à
cette huile d'olive et c'est ce qui fait
la richesse de ces plats alors avec ce
plat on vous sert un vin rosé qui est un
vin de Provence que vous souhaitiez
mettre en avant parce que c'est un vin
qui vient de l'étang de Berre exactement
sur les pourtours de l'étang de Berre
c'est un vin qui a été qui a été
médaillée et pourquoi est-ce que je vais
en parler pas seulement pour sa qualité
mais c'est aussi pour mettre en avant
les temps de Berre
pas de secret mais l'imaginaire
collectif
et notamment en imaginaire parisien
les temps de Berne n'a pas forcément une
bonne image et donc moi mon combat c'est
de pouvoir donner une autre image de
l'étang de berges j'ai porté un rapport
sur la réhabilitation des temps de verre
avec deux députés d'étiquettes
politiques différentes c'était pierre
d'arriville et Eric Diard de
l'enseignement nature qui ont permis
d'avancer sur un certain nombre de
propositions permettant d'améliorer
justement cette image améliorer le sujet
de la qualité de l'eau et puis il y a
des spécificités autour de ce pourtour
de l'étang de Berg et ce rosé ce rosé de
qualité en est une et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il me semble important que
nous puissions le partager voilà
appellation coteau d'Aix-en-Provence un
millésime 2021 en fait les vins de rosés
il faut les boire dans l'année en
général parce que c'est ce sont des vins
qui généralement ce ne sont pas des vins
de garde les cépages alors vous les
connaissez bien j'imagine grenade
Carignan sans eau et puis Siram ou
reverbes ou Cabernet Sauvignon ça dépend
si c'est un un vin qui est vinifié en
pressage ou en paresseux par pressurage
ou par ou par saigner en fait soit on
presse le raisin et puis on récupère
tout de suite dans dans les les minutes
qui viennent le 20 et donc c'est un vin
très clair très rose et très pâle ça
c'est un vin de saigner donc ça mature
un petit peu 12 à 14h avec les pots et
sa colore davantage le vin celui-là est
peut-être de saigner si on regarde sa
couleur effectivement ça vous plaît vous
aimez ça ça va bien en fait c'est accord
mes vins avec la soupe au pistou
exactement et on retrouve si vous voulez
l'ambiance des après-midi enfin des
déjeuners des soirées
en Provence ou à la fois vous partagez
mon appareil cette soupe au pistou aussi
des rosés des rosés de qualité qui se
sont améliorés au fil du temps et ça il
faut le dire grâce au travail on a
quasiment toute l'année maintenant du
rosé alors qu'avant c'était considéré
comme un bain de seconde
qualité pour bien comprendre votre
réhabilitation de l'étang de bercer ce
sont des vignes qui étaient anciennes et
vous réhabiliter ce vin ou au contraire
ce sont des vignes qui ont été plantés
pour réhabiliter les temps de baisse
c'est à dire que sur les pourtours de
l'étang de mer vous avez à la fois des
vignes enseigne anciennes et puis il y a
une volonté aussi de faire évoluer le
vignoble et vous avez beaucoup de
d'agriculteurs de viticulteurs qui
s'engagent sur cette démarche là mais
aussi dans leur capacité aussi à
produire autrement et à donner une autre
dimension à leur à leur vignoble
d'accord alors on va voir maintenant si
vous êtes vraiment incollables c'est le
quiz
alors je suis sûr qu'il fait partie de
votre imaginaire aussi c'est l'écrivain
et cinéaste Marcel Pagnol qui avait un
art consommé pour mêler littérature et
Cuisine Dans quel de ces films étaient
énoncés cette aphorisme c'est un
aphoriste fait quelque chose qu'on
assure avec autorité la truite il faut
qu'elle saute de la rivière dans la
casserole pour qu'elle soit fraîche bien
entendu alors c'est dans La Fille du
puisatier réponse a lettre réponse B des
lettres de mon moulin réponse C la femme
du boulanger réponse d cigales
je dirais que c'est dans La Fille du
puisatier non c'est B c'est dans les
lettres de mon moulin qui est une
adaptation du roman d'Alphonse Daudet
par le cinéaste Marcel Pagnol je vois
que je n'ai pas beaucoup de succès
il y a toujours des pièges dans ses
couilles je j'ai vu que beaucoup de
collègues se faisaient piégés par vos
quiz qui sont d'une voilà qui sont très
travaillés qui ne sont pas simples vous
pouvez vous rattraper deuxième quiz les
cuisines françaises et italiennes se
sont très proches et ce sont
mutuellement nourris alors sauriez-vous
nous dire qui doit acquis alors à les
glaces est-ce que c'est la France où
est-ce que c'est l'Italie
la béchamel les artichauts et la
fourchette alors si on commence par les
glaces ça vient d'où à votre avis ça
vient de France
bravo les artichauts alors ça vient ça
vient d'Italie ça vient d'Italie et
c'est en France
à ma maman qui fait des artichauts à la
barrigoule
mais c'est les Italiens qui ont été les
premiers à les cuisiner et ensuite les
c'est venu en France c'est pas très loin
l'Italie et là fourchette
de France donc la fourchette là on est
contre la parité ici on est plus italien
que français
c'est l'Italie effectivement est-ce que
vous vous aimez faire le marché est-ce
que vous faites attention à ce que vous
consommez bio pas bio local alors je
fais très attention à ce que je consomme
dès que je peux faire le marché je le
fais parce que c'est l'occasion aussi
d'être d'échanger avec nos agriculteurs
c'est de pouvoir tout simplement aussi
être accessible sur ces marchés et puis
et puis à côté de ça moi ce que je
regarde pas enfin je veux je veux une
agriculture de qualité mais je ne
consomme pas que du bio ce qui
m'intéresse et que ça soit consommé en
local et j'imagine que voilà dans les
légumes que vous nous proposez là tout
n'est pas bio il faut avant tout faire
la promotion du local et à côté de ça si
on peut avoir du bio c'est une bonne
chose aussi donc en trois produits bio
espagnol et un produit local voilà il y
a un produit avec des pesticides des
intrants ce n'est pas aussi simple que
ça vous le savez mais moi je prône avant
tout du local vous nous aviez demandé
soit de la bouillabaisse soit de la
soupe au pistou et c'est à dire que vous
ne mangez pas de viande ou vous avez
peut-être réduit votre attention là
aussi à la viande que je consomme je
consomme très peu de viande mais lorsque
j'en achète c'est dans le boucher de la
rue des Frères Kennedy j'ai deux bouché
en face de ma permanence parlementaire à
Salon-de-Provence où là je vais chercher
d'une viande je sais de qualité et c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui compte manger moins
mais manger mieux alors on a connu le
politiquement correct sur des grands
sujets de société je sais pas
l'immigration par exemple est-ce que le
politiquement correct est pas en train
de gangrener la parole sur la nourriture
ici plus personne n'ose nous dire qu'ils
veulent manger de la viande est-ce que
vous y avez pensé exclusivement si je
commence à dire qu'on va manger de la
viande de la FNSE peut-être non mais
voyez je vous le dis j'ai pas de
difficulté lorsque je suis invité si il
y a la viande mais je mange de la viande
non mais de déclarer d'assumer d'en
manger de nous dire j'aurais bien aimé à
la place de la soupe au pistou une bonne
entrecôte
je pense qu'il faut qu'on consomme moins
de viande ça je la firme j'ai aucune
difficulté mais c'est pas à cause de
l'air ambiance c'est une conviction
c'est pas la ambiance et d'ailleurs
d'être député et on parlait tout à
l'heure de course à pied si on veut bien
s'entraîner il faut faire attention à la
consommation de viande rouge est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ne faut plus manger
de viande rouge il faut en manger mais
sans doute une quantité un peu moins
importante et surtout privilégier la
qualité je le répète alors on sait qu'en
France le repas occupe une assez large
place et c'est souvent autour d'un bon
plat que ce nous les meilleures
histoires et que se fait aussi la petite
et la et la grande histoire c'est la
brève de comptoir
alors Jean-Marc voulait dire on fait ça
demander de réfléchir à une anecdote
politique pourquoi pas autour d'un repas
est-ce que vous avez une histoire à nous
raconter alors je n'ai pas une histoire
particulière à avoir raconté j'aurais pu
parce que j'ai quand même de bons
souvenirs de repas je me souviens
lorsque Emmanuel Macron était venu à
Marseille lors de sa campagne en 2017 il
avait fait un repas organisé par mon
suppléant Philippe Véran pour justement
bien échanger avec
voilà ces soutiens tout ça donc ça reste
un bon souvenir j'aurais pu vous parler
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
Jean-Claude Gaudin à côté de la mairie
de Marseille on nous a invité à déjeuner
et je le vois rentrer dans le restaurant
en me dis alors mon petit comment ça va
si toi et et et échanger mais moi s'il y
a le premier souvenir le premier sujet
qui me vient autour de la politique et
des repas c'est ce que je peux partager
avec une personne qui s'appelle yvidal
qui est mère qui était mère de la
commune de Grans il a laissé la main à
Philippe Léandri qui fera qui fait un
travail déjà exceptionnel pourquoi
est-ce que je vous parle de ça parce que
évidemment il a de l'expérience il a été
élu député le 12 juin 1988 moi je suis
né le 6 juin 1988 et lorsqu'on dit que
les parlementaires ont tendance d'être
un peu hors-sol loin des élus locaux ben
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
au-delà de nos réunions de travail que
nous pouvons faire tous les mois
régulièrement ces moments où on se
retrouve à la table de Grans où on
partage un repas ensemble où on partage
des souvenirs politiques où il peut dans
une certaine mesure me conseiller quant
aux différents choix à prendre c'est des
moments où et bien le jeune élu que je
suis apprend beaucoup et c'est des
moments autour d'un bon plat qui apporte
beaucoup tout simplement est-ce que vous
souvenez ce que vous mangez ou c'est
plutôt la conversation
que vous retenez bon on a toujours des
plats de très grande qualité mais ce qui
compte c'est de se retrouver autour d'un
moment de qualité de convivialité et que
on puisse discuter de politique et vous
voyez on lit un peu comme aujourd'hui
la cuisine et la politique autour de ces
moments qui me semblent tout à fait
pertinent pour pour un élu qui certes
n'est pas un élu local mais qui a besoin
d'être au contact de ces élus locaux qui
ont façonné le territoire et dans une
certaine mesure la France aussi
puisqu'il a été député alors vous vous
avez des sujets très concrets à traiter
en tant que président de la commission
du développement durable on va
s'intéresser à présent à la COP 27 qui
va s'ouvrir en Égypte à sharm-elcher du
7 au 18 novembre et qui va évidemment se
pencher sur le problème du réchauffement
climatique et des conséquences pour
l'agriculture certains aliments
pourraient être à terme disparaître
c'est le dessous des plats
oui avec le réchauffement climatique un
Brigitte certaines cultures pourraient
disparaître de nos campagnes vous l'avez
dit car beaucoup trop consommatrice
d'eau c'est le cas du maïs par exemple
certains agriculteurs abandonnent
carrément sa culture pour le remplacer
par une plante exotique bien moins
gourmande en eau c'est le sorgho
africain c'est un reportage de Clément
Perrot
[Musique]
la sécheresse de cet été a coûté cher à
Gaylord Goven agriculteurs céréaliers en
Touraine son maïs a été récolté il y a
trois semaines les rendements sont bons
mais à quel prix dans ces terrains-là
qui sont argiles au calcaire j'ai dû
arroser 8 fois 8 fois 30 mm ça coûte
cher d'arroser par rapport à
l'électricité à l'entretien l'entretien
des pompes la surveillance les charges à
côté il faut les payer quoi puis à la
fin des fois il reste pas grand chose
du fait des sécheresses à répétition
qu'entraîne le réchauffement climatique
la culture du maïs est de moins en moins
rentable en France alors certains s'est
réalisé comme Gaylord commencent à se
tourner vers de nouvelles cultures
beaucoup moins familières
sur cette parcelle de 18 hectares ou
l'irrigation est impossible il cultive
une plante venue d'Afrique subsaharienne
le sorgho donc là c'est les graines
qu'on récolte du sorgho
c'est pour faire de la farine pour les
animaux principalement ça remplace un
peu le maïs
[Musique]
la différence avec le maïs c'est que le
sorgho est beaucoup moins gourmand en
eau cet été il a mieux résisté à la
sécheresse
c'est des terrains ou qu'il n'y a pas
d'irrigation donc on essaie de faire des
cultures adaptées adaptées au terrain et
puis et puis aux années sèches quoi
comme
ceux du maïs à la place
du encore beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
de résultats que le que la plante du
sorgho quoi beaucoup moins moitié moins
encore je pense
ça aurait été vers 5 5 6 tonnes à
l'hectare quoi à peu près
alors que là je pense cette année du
sorgho on va peut-être réussir à faire 8
tonnes à l'hectare à peu près
face au dérèglements climatiques le
sorgho devient une alternative
séduisante pour les agriculteurs avec
68000 hectares cultivés la France et
même championne d'Europe du sorgho mais
attention cela ne représente jamais que
0,7% de la surface agricole consacrée
aux grandes cultures l'heure où le
sorgho remplacera le maïs dans nos
paysages n'a pas encore sonné
[Musique]
vous le constatez sur vos terres est-ce
que le sorgho débarque aussi dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône comme on le voit dans
ce reportage dans une Mabuse je ne l'ai
pas vu arriver à circonscrit dans le 8e
circonscription des Bouches-du-Rhône
mais je trouve ce reportage tout à fait
intéressant parce que il montre oui oui
mais intéressant édifiant mais on a une
agriculture qui est en capacité aussi
d'évoluer en a tendance à dire que les
agriculteurs n'évoluent pas etc ce
reportage montre tout le contraire et
là où je pense qu'il faut faire
attention c'est que le sorgho doit être
vu dans un premier temps avant tout
comme quelque chose de complémentaire on
peut pas dire qu'il va remplacer le maïs
demain
parce que vous dites on s'adapte mais ça
s'adapte il faut quand même continuer
bien sûr à produire du mails aussi
s'adaptent aussi parce que on ne fait
pas la même chose avec du maïs comme on
fait les mêmes choses qu'avec du sorgho
donc il faut aussi que les filières
s'organisent il faut que les
agriculteurs s'y retrouve aussi
financièrement et c'est à nous ce qui
est impossible de réalité là
l'adaptation parce que ça se réchauffe
mais c'est plus rentable parce que ça
coûte trop cher mais bien sûr et donc
c'est à nous aussi de pouvoir bien
organiser quand je dis ça à nous c'est à
nous politique de de d'aider à ce que la
filière s'organise de sorte à ce que
nous puissions avoir des agriculteurs
qui ont des alternatives à cette culture
du maïs est-ce que justement ça il faut
l'encourager parce que on pourrait se
demander si c'est toujours raisonnable
de cultiver du maïs c'est très très
consommateur d'eau est-ce qu'il faut pas
se dire avec le réchauffement climatique
on change on baisse est-ce que c'est un
on dit aujourd'hui enfin voilà là cette
agriculteur il commence à faire du
sorgho mais c'est pas dit en fait ce
qu'il faut se dire bon bah on va
l'arrêter sur tant d'années quoi vous
avez raison mais
de ma place il y a aussi un devoir de
responsabilité pour proposer une
alternative qui soit crédible et qui
permettent à l'agriculteur qui se lève
tôt le matin et qui se couche très tard
le soir d'avoir une alternative qui lui
permet de gagner bien sa vie et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est notre
responsabilité de structurer cette
filière de aussi d'accompagner les
différentes agriculteurs sur
comment cultiver le sorgho dans quelle
mesure est-ce que ça vient en complément
du maïs de sorte à ce que le sorgho
puisse prendre de plus en plus de place
dans notre agriculture et que dans
quelques années sans doute ils viennent
se substituer au maïs alors là on le
voit c'est pas encore tout à fait
rentable c'est pas encore une affaire
pour ça qu'il faut absolument structurer
finalement chez nous pour le sorgho je
fais confiance à l'avenir sur le fait
que sans doute il fera de plus en plus
chaud et c'est notre rôle de pouvoir
justement faire face à ce cette
réchauffement climatique alors c'est pas
le quiz mais c'est quand même une
propriété dingue le sorgo c'est
lorsqu'il s'arrête de pleuvoir il se met
en arrêt et il se remet à repousser la
prochaine pluie alors que lorsque le
maïs vit une période de sécheresse il
meurt sur pied alors que là vraiment il
s'est un aliment une plante magique
il y a une vraie résilience de la plante
et il attend la prochaine pluie pour
redémarrer il faut le faire toucher
aussi le sorghost c'est ce qu'on ne dit
pas à là forcément dans le portage donc
le faire sécher c'est aussi des coups en
matière d'énergie aujourd'hui
et qu'on va pas le remplacer du jour du
jour au lendemain et vous voyez ce matin
on auditionnait l'ambassadrice de la
COP15 qui disait écartez-vous de toutes
les solutions simpliste qui vous sont
proposées parce que vous le voyez bien
quand vous bâtissez des solutions
alternatives qui nous sont présentés
comme la solution et bien toujours il y
a toujours un inconvénient derrière
qu'il faut être en capacité d'anticiper
qu'est-ce que ça peut être les
alternatives aujourd'hui pour les
agriculteurs face au réchauffement
climatique je pense par exemple déplacer
des zones de production à produire autre
chose à d'autres endroits ou de les
faire de la polyculture faire tourner
ses cultures c'est quoi les solutions
qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui le sorgho
permet en complément de d'améliorer la
rotation des
des différentes cultures donc ça c'est
une bonne chose
et à côté de ça il faut accompagner
justement dans la diversification des
cultures de sorte à ce que ils puissent
avoir un revenu décent à la fin de
l'année
ceci étant dit on
peut se faire aussi l'autocritique sur
les lois égalimes à la fois 1 la loi
Gallim 2 sur la nécessité de continuer à
travailler sur les revenus de nos
agriculteurs
lorsque vous faites lorsque vous êtes
maraîchers ça demande beaucoup beaucoup
de travail je ne suis pas certain que
les revenus soient à la hauteur de
l'effort engagé et c'est ce qui fait
notamment que il y a une crise de
vocation des agriculteurs donc ça c'est
aussi le deuxième point diversification
mieux payer les agriculteurs et puis le
troisième point et ça j'insiste c'est le
sujet du Zéro artificialisation nette
que nous avons acté dans la loi climat
résilience il faut absolument absolument
préserver nos terres agricoles je sais
qu'il y a une volonté
certains territoires de revenir sur
cette ambition là plus construire sur
des terres agricoles il faut absolument
sanctuariser nos terres agricoles de
sorte à ce que nous puissions continuer
à produire et à nourrir nos vous ai pas
parlé de la recherche est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas aussi faire de la recherche
pour développer des OGM des des plantes
qui seraient plus résistantes face à ce
réchauffement des OGM est un peu un
tabou il faut qu'il y ait un débat de
notre côté sans parler d'OGM aujourd'hui
parce que vous avez compris que à quel
point c'est un sujet sensible et ça je
peux le comprendre vous avez raison sur
la nécessité de mettre le paquet sur la
recherche sur le développement de sorte
que la France soit leader à la fois sur
les semences mais aussi sur cette
capacité à faire face à la fois au
réchauffement climatique mais aussi à de
nombreuses maladies et c'est pour ça
aussi que vous savez au niveau européen
on a cette fameuse stratégie de la
fourche à la fourchette
moi j'ai beaucoup poussé pour que ça on
dise pas de la fourche à la fourchette
mais de la graine
à la fourchette
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur non plus
que ces changements de culture
bouleversent les AOP par exemple ça peut
être la fin de nos terroirs protégés
imaginons un camembert fabriqué avec des
vaches nourries au sorgho il perd son
AOP et c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure
et tout ça se bouleversement vous le
vous préparez à l'idée vous préparez vos
citoyens à cette idée-là je suis attaché
100% en notre culture à la culture
française et donc je pense que il ne
faut pas imposer du jour au lendemain
une solution parce que en imposant du
jour au lendemain par exemple du sorgho
et bien il y a des conséquences à la
fois sur des fromages il y a des
conséquences même sur le fonctionnement
d'une exhiatation sans doute sur les
viandes aussi
et donc il faut le faire en complément
et en travaillant toutes les filières
main dans la main entre
exploitants politiques de sorte à ce que
nous puissions trouver des solutions et
des solutions qui soient partagées de
tous et crédibles alors dites le maïs
consomme beaucoup d'eau vous avez du
cette guerre de l’eau qui a eu lieu le
week-end dernier regardez cette image à
Sainte Soline dans les Deux Sèvres une
manifestation de plusieurs milliers de
personnes a tourné à l'affrontement
contre donc un projet de bassine et les
manifestants ont tenté de forcer le
chantier de cette réserve d'eau alors
que cette manifestation était interdite
on le rappelle des gaz lacrymogènes ont
été lancées plusieurs dizaines de
personnes ont été blessées dont 61
gendarmes quelques 1500 gendarmes sont
encore sur les lieux pour sécuriser le
projet et éviter l'établissement d'une
ZAD quand vous voyez c'est ces
écologistes qui défendent l'eau en
disant c'est un bien public finalement
elle appartient à tout le monde pourquoi
les agriculteurs ont le droit de la
capter qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez
alors on s'accorde tous sur le fait de
dire que l'eau étant bien
précieux que la ressource en eau
de plus en plus se poser là raréfaction
de la ressource en eau va de plus en
plus se poser dans les années à venir
mais il y a des manières de manifester
surtout d'une manifestation qui était
interdite et la manière dont il porte
leur revendications me semble en fin de
compte assez assez contre-productif
parce que au final moi lorsque j'en
parle avec des personnes de ma
circonscription j'étais ce weekend sur
le terrain
les citoyens
sont assez choqués par la manière dont
les manifestants
mais mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
porte une cause vous savez je le dis
très directement j'ai participé à des
manifestations sur le sujet de la
réhabilitation de l'étang de guerre
notamment devant la centrale de
l'électrique de Saint-Chamas est-ce que
j'ai tout cassé est-ce que j'ai cassé la
centrale hydroélectrique ce combat va
trop loin là pour je pense que ce combat
va trop loin et il discrédite la cause
que porte ces manifestes c'est la guerre
de l'eau c'est une captation d'un bien
public vous l'avez dit on l'eau c'est ça
appartient aussi à tout le monde c'est
un projet qui est autorisé par ce qu'a
dit le ministre de l'Agriculture
pourquoi il est autorisé ce projet
finalement parce que ce qui répond à un
besoin il répond à la nécessité de
pouvoir continuer à produire sur un
territoire donné même en allant pomper
les nappes phréatiques qui vont donc
faire moins d'eau pour le reste de la
population lorsque on dit simplement
qu'on va pomper les nappes phréatiques
ça choque tout le monde lorsqu'on dit on
va pomper les nappes au moment où elle
se régénère exactement et en particulier
dans les périodes
c'est en cela qu'il faut être très
visible surplus d'eau c'est vraiment le
surplus d'eau d'une part et puis je
pense qu'il y a sur ce sujet des
bassines
de ces stockages d'eau il faut aussi
mettre en avant la nécessité de capter
l'eau lorsqu'elle en quantité et je
pense que c'est un principe qui me
semble être juste que de dire que au
moment où l'eau est en quantité nous la
stockons et lorsque nous agriculteurs en
ont besoin notamment l'été et bien
partageons cette ressource c'est pas
simplement le sujet pour les
agriculteurs c'est être en capacité
d'avoir ce qu'il faut dans nos assiettes
sinon les agriculteurs ne sont pas en
capacité de produire et non pas par
définition de l'eau et de l'eau de
qualité et bien c'est une question de
souveraineté alimentaire de notre pays
mais encourager ses bassines est-ce que
ça encourage pas l'agriculture intensive
finalement c'est ce que disent aussi les
écologistes derrière tout ça ils sont
censés faire des efforts les
agriculteurs mais on les voit pas
vraiment sur le terrain en tout cas à
côté un reportage vous aviez un
agriculteur qui changeait ses modes de
production donc oui vous avez des
agriculteurs et la majorité des
agriculteurs ont contrôlé vraiment parce
qu'ils utilisent quand même tous autour
visiblement encore des pesticides une
volonté d'avancer et
et en 5 ans moi j'ai vu
tout un tas de filières évoluées sur
leur pratique exactement alors on va
parler à présent de la grive voltaïsme
qui se développe dans les exploitations
agricoles justement les panneaux fleuris
sur les fermes mais aussi dans les
champs on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le plat
[Musique]
installez des panneaux solaires un
investissement rentable pour les
agriculteurs mais aussi un moyen de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique un pari gagnant-gagnant pour
Johann qui est maraîcher près de Saintes
en Charente-Maritime et qui fut l'un des
tous premiers à équiper sa serre il y a
8 ans reportages Emily spertino et
Augustin François Poncet
à première vue cela ressemble à une
cercle classique mais il s'agit d'une
serre photovoltaïque comme ça
donc là vous avez tous les panneaux qui
sont qui sont le versant sud des
panneaux solaires qui recouvrent la
moitié des trois hectares de cette
exploitation en Charente-Maritime
Johann Bernardin maraîcher n'y voit que
des avantages c'est-à-dire l'été ça va
faire de l'ombrage aux plantes ce qui
fera que ça va protéger des brûlures et
en même temps plus il y a de soleil plus
on va créer l'énergie de l'énergie
renouvelable qui sera redistribué sur le
réseau et qui aujourd'hui va alimenter
toute l'électricité de ma commune il y a
8 ans quand il se lance dans le projet
de cette serre photovoltaïque beaucoup
autour de lui sont sceptiques sous des
panneaux jamais ça poussera
c'était la phrase typique qu'on
entendait et voilà c'était vraiment sous
des panneaux avec 50% d'ombre il y a
aucune plante qui va pousser aujourd'hui
on démonte que c'est pas vrai il a fallu
apprendre à travailler autrement c'est à
dire qu'il a fallu revoir toute notre
technicité agricole c'est-à-dire les
apports d'engrais les apports d'arrosage
en fait on reprend à travailler sous une
serre photovoltaïque pour s'offrir cette
serre de 3 millions d'euros Johan
Bernardin a signé un bail de 30 ans avec
un promoteur photovoltaïque ce dernier
finance la structure et fait des
bénéfices grâce à la revente d'énergie
solaire l'agriculteur lui reste
propriétaire de son sol et de ses
rendements pour Johan c'est du
gagnant-gagnant
c'est à dire que moi voilà aujourd'hui
j'ai un outil de travail grâce à la
vente d'énergie que j'aurais jamais pu
j'ai un confort de travail j'ai une
sécurité de l'emploi pour mes employés
et je me dis que ce bâtiment je l'ai pas
fait que pour moi je l'ai fait pour mes
génération après qui j'espère se servira
de ce que j'ai conçu aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir continuer à faire notre premier
métier c'est donner à manger aux gens le
maraîcher est conscient que certains
agriculteurs pourraient être tentés
d'accepter n'importe quel projet pour
s'assurer une sécurité économique mais
pour lui ce cas reste très marginal on
va pas faire n'importe quoi on va pas
prendre des terrains pour faire que de
l'énergie c'est pas vrai je sais que la
chance qu'on a c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut un permis de construire qui est
géré par les chambres d'Agris par les
communes et si la commune dit non il y
aura pas de permis de construire bah
forcément il y aura pas de projet photoé
Johan lui a obtenu la permission de
faire construire une seconde serre
agrippoltaïque plus étendue encore que
la première elle accueillera des
cultures exclusivement bio
Jean-Marc zoulisier est-ce que le modèle
convient de voir avec cette serre
immense avec ses panneaux
photovoltaïques qui s'inclinent est-ce
que ça c'est le modèle de l'agriculture
de demain ça fera partie du modèle de
l'agriculture de demain encore une fois
l'agriculture de demain ne dépendra pas
que de ce modèle là en revanche à partir
du moment où c'est c'est cher existent
est-ce que on n'est pas en capacité de
pouvoir bien de les exploiter de sorte à
ce que en mettant ses panneaux solaires
comme ça très bien été expliqué dans
votre reportage on puisse arriver avant
un revenu complémentaire et j'insiste
bien sur le revenu complémentaire parce
que ce revenu il doit pas être il ne
doit pas être plus important que les
revenus
mal les agriculteurs est-ce qu'on va pas
continuer à manger
peut-être exactement complémentaire
supplémentaire l'appeler comme vous
voulez et puis le deuxième point où là
je pense que on doit absolument être
très Vig c'est sur les contrats avec les
agriculteurs les opérateurs de
photovoltaïques exactement là dans votre
reportage si je ne m'abuse l'agriculteur
est lié pendant 30 ans il faut
absolument que les modalités soient bien
travaillées de sorte à ce que
l'agriculteur ne se sentent pas lésé au
bout de 10 ans 15 ans
très gros investissement
lié pendant 30 ans mais il y a forcément
je pense des modalités dans son contrat
mais je pense qu'il faut faire attention
sur ces modèles là et on a vu dans le
passé que ce type de modèle pouvait
avoir des inconvénients des
inconvénients aussi économiques mais
aussi sur le sujet de sa propriété c'est
à dire si demain il ne veut plus de
serre sur cet endroit là comment fait-on
et est-ce qu'on a assez de recul
finalement là-dessus parce que là tout
le monde lui disait alors si tu mets tes
panneaux photovoltaïques que tu pourras
plus
avoir des cultures qui seront aussi
belles qu'avant parce qu'il y aura moins
de lumière est-ce que ça marche pour
toutes les cultures et est-ce que par
exemple il y a pas de risque pour
l'élevage sur la reproduction des
animaux par exemple avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques au dessus est-ce qu'on a
assez de recul les premiers retours que
nous avons sont plutôt bénéfiques sont
plutôt
montre que ça va plutôt dans le bon sens
est-ce qu'il faut pour cela qu'il faut
s'arrêter à cela non il faut continuer à
travailler sans que c'est un peu notre
rôle on un texte de loi sur les EnR sur
le déploiement des ENR sur justement la
définition de ce qu'on appelle la
grivevoltaïsme comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à le déployer tout en respectant
le déploiement aussi de notre culture
d'énergie renouvelable c'est notre rôle
d'assurer moi ce que j'appelle le
service après-vente c'est à dire de
s'assurer que ça s'applique
convenablement sur le terrain et que le
principe que j'ai fixé tout à l'heure
sur le fait que l'activité principale de
l'agriculteur doit être de produire des
aliments et non pas de produire de
l'électricité soit respecté alors là il
se fait de l'ombrage effectivement quand
il y a du soleil donc c'est bien pour le
réchauffement climatique aussi c'est
bien aussi quand il y a du gel ça ça
est-ce que ça ça permet d'avoir ces
panneaux photovoltaïques au-dessus des
cultures par exemple de préserver une
certaine température alors ça n'a pas
été c'est pas c'est pas des radiateurs
en même temps c'est pas le premier
avantage qui a été mis en avant le
premier sujet c'est avant tout la
production et cette capacité de pouvoir
protéger lorsque
le soleil tape et on sait notamment oui
mais pour rebondir sur ce que dit
Brigitte on peut à ce moment-là très
bien installé avec ses photosvoltaïques
directement des micros radiateurs qui
pourraient effectivement empêcher le gel
ça ça pourrait être valable chauffer la
serre avec l'énergie directement
produite par les toits oui sauf qu'en
hiver c'est pas là que ça produit le
plus aussi donc il faut faire attention
aussi aux modèles que l'on met derrière
et et donc tout ça s'étudie et sans
doute d'excellentes solutions derrière
mais je pense que le premier sujet c'est
de se dire face au réchauffement
climatique comment est-ce que notamment
l'été on arrive à protéger nos cultures
c'est le premier sujet on sait que la
rentabilité du photovoltaïque incite les
entreprises ainsi intéressées vous le
faisiez allusion tout à l'heure et ça
crée des effets pervers en effet le
rachat des terres agricoles à prix d'or
existent la présidente de la Chambre
d'Agriculture de la Seine-et-Marne a
justement alerté il n'y a pas très
longtemps là-dessus on l'écoute
l'agriculture sur le photovoltaïque au
sol elle est vend debout elle est vend
debout contre l'utilisation de ces
terres agricoles nous voulons préserver
la fonction alimentaire nourricière de
nos de nos de nos sols il y a
suffisamment mais ça c'est bien mis
aussi dans la loi de friche de bâtiments
industriels de couverture de parking de
Bordeaux à couvrir sans aller chercher
de la terre agricole et je vous alerte
sur le fait que nous sommes démarchés
quotidiennement dans nos exploitations
par des opérateurs pour mettre du
photovoltaïque au sol et la plupart des
agriculteurs nous avons un devoir
d'informations auprès de ses
agriculteurs nous avons la nécessité de
leur dire que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
dans le dans la fonction que nous
voulons attribuer à l'agriculture et
pourtant les tarifs qui sont proposés
aux agriculteurs sont très attractifs et
mettent à mal le fait que vous savez
quand vous produisez de la viande ou du
lait vous n'êtes pas rémunéré qu'en face
on vous propose de la production
d'énergie en utilisant le sol et en ne
faisant plus rien évidemment donc c'est
à vous les parlementaires de mettre les
garde-fous nécessaires pour que il nous
soignent que certains d'entre nous ne
soient pas séduits par ce par ce type de
démarche
Jean-Marc Élise la présidente
d'agriculture la Seine-et-Marne dit
attention parce qu'on peut mettre des
panneaux fauteuils voltaïques au sol pas
comme avant là sur le haut de la serre
mais vraiment au sol sur des terres
agricoles il faut pas l'interdire ça
alors je vais répondre à votre question
mais ça me permet de d'introduire le
concept qu'on a mis en place dans la
commission Développement Durable
l'aménagement du territoire puisque
cette séquence a été tournée lorsque
nous avons réalisé ce que j'appelle moi
la commission hors les murs vous avez
des parlementaires dans été justement à
vos côtés du conseil départemental de
Seine-Maritime nous aviez à la fois des
conseils départementaux des
parlementaires des élus de chambre
consulaire et on a pu débattre sur le
sujet du déploiement des ENR et et fruit
de ces discussions on a ce type
d'intervention
[Musique]
législation moi j'ai lu qui avait des
mères qui
transformaient des terres arabes en
terre a urbaniser entre guillemets et
donc ça laissait la porte ouverte au
photovoltaïque il y a un principe dans
cette maison c'est la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales mais vous avez raison et
c'est qu'une minorité de merde
c'est qu'une minorité de mer et
l'ensemble des mers que j'ai rencontré
souhaite garder ces terres agricoles et
éviter absolument ce type de pratique
faut-il dans la loi sans doute clarifier
un certain nombre de choses de sorte à
ce que nous puissions sanctuaire c'était
agricole la réponse est oui au regard de
ce que vous venez de mettre justement
vous avez un projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables qui est
actuellement en discussion au Sénat qui
va arriver après à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose prévu
pour les terres agricoles justement et
le photovoltaïsme et ce projet de loi
qui a pour but d'accélérer de faciliter
l'installation des énergies Runner ne
renouvelables ne va-t-il pas du coup à
l'encontre de de ces terres agricoles
qui pourraient
avec des panneaux plus rapidement prévu
à la fois dans ce que le Sénat et je
crois que c'est aujourd'hui dans la
période là ils sont en train de discuter
du texte en séance mais de ce qui sort
notamment de la commission au Sénat à
aucun moment il y a une volonté de venir
et bien construire sur des terres
agricoles accélérées sur des terres
agricoles et faites confiance à la
commission Développement Durable
d'aménagement du territoire pour
préserver pour garantir ce principe qui
est qui est essentiel du coup vous allez
rajouter quelques amendements là presque
vous avez entendu je préfère attendre de
voir le texte de loi assorti du Sénat
pour vous dire on va rajouter absolument
quelque chose mais oui il y a une
volonté et une volonté de travailler sur
ce sujet de sorte à ce qu'on ne confonde
pas vitesse et précipitations au-delà du
fait qu'on entame un peu de notre
souveraineté alimentaire en consacrant
des terres arables à des
photosvoltaïques question que j'ai eu
c'est sans doute des écolos logistes ou
des amoureux de la nature qui le disent
des photosvoltaïques dans des champs ça
peut aussi nuire aux abeilles aux fleurs
et petit oiseau est-ce que c'est vrai
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une évaluation
environnementale qui permet justement de
pouvoir évaluer tout ceci donc la
réponse et oui mais dans dans chaque
acte
humain il y a des conséquences sur notre
écosystème d'où la nécessité de bien
préserver des études d'impact qui ont du
sens etc mais je reviens juste sur le
reportage que vous avez montré juste
avant la commission hors les murs il est
en aucun cas souhaité devenir médecin au
sol c'est vraiment sur des serres et
donc ça vient en complément d'une
activité actuelle allez on va passer au
dessert à présent et c'est le péché
mignon
brigitte a c'est le temps du sucré avec
une tarte aux abricots et là il faut
éclaircir les choses monsieur le député
avec Brigitte on vous pose la question
quel drôle d'idée ces abricots en boîte
non alors je sais que sous le soleil de
la Canebière on pense que l'été c'est
toute l'année mais non au pays de Plus
Belle La Vie monsieur il y a encore
quatre saisons et belle lurette que les
abricots ont disparu alors faute de
grive et bien voici des oreillons
d'abricots au sirop en fait c'est
peut-être comme ça que vous les préférez
vous alors j'avais une autre idée votre
maman avec la soupe au pistou elle fait
des conserves d'abricots alors j'avais
proposé des calissons j'avais proposé
des navettes on m'a dit mais non il faut
un vrai dessert bon donc du coup je me
suis tourné vers les abricots mais ça
permet aussi de dire que effectivement
on peut faire des concerts
toute l'année de qualité mais ce qui me
permet aussi de dire que derrière cette
tarte aux abricots en boîte alors
il y a normalement des amandes j'avais
demandé qui ait des amendes pourquoi
est-ce que je vous parle des amandes
parce que
d'ailleurs
les amandes se consomment toute l'année
c'est un produit de Provence et on a un
vrai enjeu un vrai enjeu de structurer
là aussi une filière de production
d'amandes parce que notamment pour faire
des calissons
en Provence on essaye de faire de
travailler avec des producteurs locaux
mais je sais que d'autres personnes
et bien exportent
importe pardon importe des amendes qui
viennent soit de Turquie soit de
Californie alors que on a tout ce qu'il
faut en France on est autosuffisant en
amande c'est ce que vous souhaitez
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on n'est pas du
tout auto suffisant bien au contraire
mais il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs
lorsque vous faites des oliviers lorsque
vous faites pourquoi pas des abricots
pourquoi pas à côté accompagner les
agriculteurs à faire des amendes de
sorte que ça puisse profiter à
l'économie l'opération et vous les
amendes sont bien là je viens de goûter
goûter là et à l'aveugle on va se
demander on va se poser la question
honnêtement si on fait la différence
entre des oreillons d'abricot sirop ou
des abricots frais
quand vous goûter qu'est-ce que vous
dites je crains que oui
c'est pas si simple que ça je trouve
c'est pas si simple c'est vrai que c'est
pas si simple
c'est vrai qu'ils sont une belle
conserve alors
on sent bien la pâte d'amande c'était un
dessert que vous mangiez petit ou pas du
tout pas particulièrement mais c'est
l'occasion de mettre en avant aussi
des produits qui sont cultivés en
Provence une nouvelle fois et c'est
l'occasion aussi de dire de faire le
lien avec l'agriculture parce que dans
certains chambres d'abricot vous avez
aussi pour protéger ces champs là de
l'agrivoltaïsme qui commence à se mettre
en place si à vous tous de nous suivre
aussi et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP
[Musique]